- Dude, I can't.
[scoffs] That
ain't gonna cut it.
MAN: No, no winner.
MAN: Nope, no winner.
Story of my life.
You want to come up here?
I think someone found
your missing teeth.
[laughter]
[honking]
MAN: Holy [bleep].
MAN: Like I said, it's
bright yellow, man.
Yeah, it's a hot bike, man.
MAN: I'm coming to the pawn shop
today to pawn my motorcycle,
because my business is
in the auto industry,
and the auto industry
is doing really poorly.
So I got to ask,
man, why would
you pawn a bike like this?
I got to make payroll.
I got employees that
count on me, you know?
Pawning is basically the
simplest form of credit.
You give us an item that
we take as collateral,
and then we'll give you cash.
You pay us back our
money with interest,
and you get your item
back, simple as that.
So what are you
looking to get out of it?
I need to get 20
grand to make payroll.
20 grand, that's going to
be rough on it though, man.
I'll be back to get it.
I'll get the money.
It's a nice bike, man,
but we're looking around 8.
8 thou-- dude, I can't.
That ain't gonna cut it.
I'll tell you what, man, I'll
meet you in the middle at 15
if it helps you out.
How long do I have until
I can get it back out?
You can get it back
out tomorrow if you want.
But I mean, you've got 120 days.
I mean like, I got 120 days?
Yeah.
All right.
And what happens after 120
days if I don't come get it?
You'll see me riding his
bike down the street, man.
All right, I'll do the deal.
I got to make payroll.
All right.
Let's go back inside
and write it up.
So what do we got here?
An early '30s
antique slot machine.
So if I buy it, do I
get all the nickels in it?
No, no.
I know at one point, this
used to dispense mints.
That's what they called
it-- a mint dispenser.
When you'd hit the jackpot,
the mints would come down there
and drop out.
Yeah, they did try and change
a lot of the gaming machines
around so that it would
win a little prize
or something like that.
The coins went out, but the
bartender would say, OK,
you won, and pay you in cash.
Give it a pull, pops.
See if it works.
[clattering]
MAN: No, no winner.
MAN: Nope, no winner.
Yeah, story of my life.
[laughter]
What are you looking
to do with this, son?
I'd like to sell it.
What do you
consider a fair price?
$3,000.
Restored, they're
worth like, $2,500.
Yeah.
And the shape right here,
it's worth right around $1,200.
Which means I can give
you like, $800 for it.
What if I were to pawn it?
If you want to pawn it, just
want to get a loan against it,
I'd loan you $500, and
you can pick it up later.
Yeah, I'll do that.
All right, deal.
How are you doing?
- All right.
- What you got here?
I am looking upon my
collection of shark teeth.
Collection of
shark teeth, huh?
Hey, Rick, you want
to come up here
I think someone found
your missing teeth.
So where did you get these?
Well, when I was 12 years
old, I was on a family vacation,
my mom picked this up for me.
And ever since then, I've
been collecting them.
All right.
Damn, this is a big one.
That's kind of the pride
of the fleet right there.
These were from megalodon,
which was a prehistoric shark.
And from the size of this
tooth, the guy was probably
bigger than a city bus.
That was a big shark.
And you want to pawn them?
Yeah, I'd rather
pawn them to sell.
This means too much
to me to sell them.
How much did you
need to borrow?
I wanted to try and
borrow about $1,000.
These are really cool.
The bigger they are, the
more expensive they are.
I have 3 million year
old rocks in my back yard
that I can't sell
them, but these I can.
I could 1,000 buck on them.
No problem.
- OK.
Write him up, Chum.
Earlier this week, I got
a call from a guy who
said he needed upon his truck.
He said it was a
very expensive truck,
we really didn't go into it, so
I told him maybe over Wally's,
and I'll see what I can do.
[honk]
Holy [bleep].
MAN: This is probably the top
of the line, one of the top line
Volvo Trucks.
It's a 780.
It comes with the Cummins
500 horsepower motor.
You get air ride
on both back axles.
This one comes with air ride
on your front axle as well.
It's got the extended cab.
This is about the most
expensive truck I've ever owned.
So why do you want
to get rid of it?
I don't want to get rid of it.
I just want to get a loan on it.
Got some family business
I need to take care of,
and get back, handle that.
Things do happen.
This in my collateral
I got here.
How much did you
need to borrow?
I got the truck for,
like, maybe $125,000.
I'm not looking for that, I'm
looking for maybe $20,000.
Take care of what I need, and
hopefully come back, and pick
her up, and keep on trucking.
[laughter]
So Wally's going
to check it out,
make sure there's no problems.
And if there isn't,
we should have deal.
- Sounds like a deal.
- OK.
All right, thanks man.
Went through and did
all the service on it,
and checked it out.
Everything looks really good.
Thanks so much, Wally,
I really appreciate it.
- We'll get you out of here now.
- OK.
All I got to do now is drive
the truck back to the shop,
and get the guy his 20 grand.
Breaker, breaker 1-9,
Big Hoss, John Lee?
Big daddy's coming home.
[laughs]